well let's return to our top story this
morning get more reaction to yesterday's
budget now from the labor party and I'm
joined Now by The Shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves hello good morning
um there's lots of people would argue
the chancellor is doing rather well and
his Autumn statement steadied the market
didn't scare the horses the predictions
of Doom haven't yet been realized uh are
we reestablishing a successful economy
here
well this was supposed to be a budget
for growth yesterday yet the office of
budget responsibility downgraded the
growth forecasts and it is growth that
we desperately need in our economy to
lift living standards to keep taxes low
and have the money that we need for our
Public Services that's why labor have
made growth the number one mission for
an incoming labor government led by KIA
stalma an ambition to have the highest
sustained growth in the G7 with our
plans for example our green Prosperity
plan our plans to make Britain the best
place to start and grow a business and
our reform to business rates practical
things to lift growth off the floor
where it's been this last decade or so
but you know the chancellor in terms of
business announced the fact that
businesses can can expend huge amounts
of their outgoings now that will help
growth won't it well obviously it's not
as not as generous as the scheme that it
is replacing but we do have course
welcome any support to help businesses
invest it was what businesses were
calling for it's indeed what I called
for at the manufacturing make UK
conference just last week but businesses
want certainty and the problem with
business taxes these last few days years
is they've gone up and down like a yo-yo
where changes are on not just an annual
basis but even twice a year
um over the last year with corporation
tax up and then down with investment
allowances in and then out and this is
no way to run a business taxation system
because investment decisions are made
years in advance and yet businesses have
no certainty under this government of
what taxes are going to be in years in
advance it's why we've said that we
would set out a tax framework for
businesses that would last a parliament
and wouldn't just change at every single
budget but the government clearly seems
to be listening to labor they've nicked
your child care policy you must be
pleased about that we are of course
where the government borrows labor
policies I'm going to welcome them
whether that is on freezing gas and
electricity bills the long overdue
changes to prepayment meters so that
people aren't charged more if they're on
prepayment meters and the child care
policies because you'll know that my
colleague Bridget Phillips and the
shadow education secretary has been
making the running on child care and as
a working mum myself I know how
important it is to have a affordable
flexible child care to meet the needs of
working parents so I welcome those
changes I would say what has taken the
government so long 13 years now of this
conservative government and only at this
stage are they beginning to recognize
how important Child Care is both for
children's development but also
crucially for our success as an economy
what about tax thresholds there's been
some criticism of the chancellor this
morning for not unfreezing the tax
thresholds uh the obr's have suggested
this leads to a essentially a 4p
increase uh an effective full Pence
increase in tax would labor remove those
or others astonished by yesterday was
that the only permanent tax giveaway was
for people who can save a million pounds
or more in their pensions while at the
same time as you rightly say ordinary
working people are facing the highest
tax burden in 70 years and the biggest
Falls in living standards ever recorded
in history that is the wrong priority to
give it so would labor unfreeze these
these tax thresholds well look the
problem is is that if I commit to do
anything like that I have to say where
the money is going to come from and so I
come back to where I started this so you
won't say you will let me let me answer
the question I'll come back to where I
started in the interview we've got to
grow the economy because it is only
through growing the economy that you can
keep taxes low improve living standards
and have the money for public services
that's why we've made it the number one
mission of an incoming labor government
if the economy had grown at the same
rates these last 13 years that they did
under the last Labor government the
average family would have 5 000 pounds
more in their pockets than they do today
that is how important growth is and so
yes I want to reduce the burden of taxes
on working people but I'm honest in
saying that that's got to be through
economic growth and we've got a plan to
get that growth but it's difficult for
viewers because we've had a number of of
of Labor politicians on this sofa this
week and when I've asked every single
one of you to to try and nail your
colors to the mass on a particular
policy how much it will cost for example
and there are no figures and it you know
we're only 18 months out of the election
people want to know whether the labor
party will reduce their taxes they need
to know a yes or no answer don't they
um well look if I started making
commitment months without saying where
the money was going to come from you'd
rightly say that's a bit but it sounds
like you're making no commitments well
no so for example we've said that we
would reverse these changes to the
pensions tax relief um because we don't
think it's the right priority to give a
tax break to the wealthiest one percent
when Ordinary People are seeing their
living standards uh decline it's why
we've said that we would extend the
windfall tax on the huge profits that
the energy Giants are making and use
that money around 10 billion pounds to
help people with the cost of living
crisis fully funded uh fully costed
plans because that is the right approach
we saw what happened last year when the
conservatives crashed the economy and
that's had lasting effects with people
paying the obr confirmed this yesterday
2 000 pounds more a year in mortgage
payments because of what the
conservatives did last year so I will
always say where the money is going to
come from will always put a fiscal
responsibility an economic
responsibility as The Rock upon which
all our announcements are made I'm not
going to pay for play fast and loosed
with the public finances in the way that
the conservatives have done back on this
pensions cap it's something of a U-turn
for labor isn't it because back in
September your health secretary the
shadow Health secretary registration
said that the party would abolish the
cap on doctors pensions I've got a quote
actually from doctors that's the key
yeah doctor's pensions yeah the
government have done though Jane is a um
a tax Barn for the richest one percent
whether the doctors are doing any other
job we want to ensure that doctors can
work extra hours but the British Medical
Association themselves gave evidence uh
to the Health and Social care select
committee last year showing that that
could be done for a fraction of the cost
of what the government announced
yesterday you don't need to spend a
billion pounds
um helping the richest one percent when
there is a fix that can be made for
doctors to ensure that they can work the
hours but isn't it isn't it true that in
the public sector there you know people
with these massive pension pots tend to
be people that have come from the public
sector because they are the ones that
have these huge pension schemes as part
of their their jobs
there are some but there's plenty of
people in the private sector it's
interesting the government of course
refused to publish all the details on uh
this yesterday but the British Medical
Association themselves gave evidence to
the select committee last year shown
that this could be done for a fraction
of the cost there's already a bespoke
scheme for example for judges for their
pensions we could have a bespoke scheme
for doctors to ensure that they work
extra hours without spending a billion
pounds in helping a people with more
than a million pounds worth of pension
savings that can't be the right priority
that's why we're forcing a vote of it on
it in the House of Commons next Tuesday
and why we've said that we would reverse
these changes if the labor were to form
the next government okay and briefly
before we let you go just to worry about
Credit Suisse how worried should we be
about a potential financial crisis after
what's happened there I am very
concerned about what's happened in the
last week with Silicon Valley Bank with
signature bank and now the issues at
Credit Suisse we've said that the
government need to look at the impact of
rapidly Rising interest rates on our
financial stability and I would urge
them to work with treasury departments
and central banks around the world to
ensure that there is the liquidity in
markets that depositors are protected
and that we preserve our hard-won
financial stability Rachel Reese thank
you very much thank you thank you